You use Quantum Physics every single day as you go about your life Something you Probably
Don't realize Because When People Talk about Quantum Physics Including
Me We tend to emphasize More Crazy
Aspects Of it like Particles That Can Be Separated by the Size of the Universe and Still communicate With each other
Instantaneously Or When Particles Could
Be in Multiple Places at Once Or multiple Positions and This Tends to Make Quantum physics Seem Like This Really Strange
Abstract Crazy Kind of Physics That doesn't have much to do with our everyday lives but this Couldn't be Further from the truth
So this is A list of five Ways, we use Quantum physics Every single day?
Number One On the List is the entire Basis of the modern World it's Computers and Computers
Wouldn't exist if It wasn't for our Understanding of Quantum Physics?
The Basic Element of Computer Is the Transistor Which is a tiny
Little Switch it's very Useful because it doesn't Have Any Moving Parts in it which is allowed us to
Miniaturize it and Have Billions of Them on a single Chip all Switching a billion Times per Second
Transistors use The Special Electronic Properties of Silicon Which is a semiconductor and the rules of Semiconductors are Dictated by Quantum Physics
Now Electrons in A semiconductor Can only Be in Certain Energy States and you Can use these energy States to create on On-off Switches
Now you can't do A whole Lot With Just Pure Silicon you need to Engineer These
Materials By Adding in Extra Elements Like Phosphorous or Boron
to Make Materials With Different Energy Levels and by combining Those Materials you can
Make a Junction Where
Normally Electrons don't flow until you apply A Voltage and Then Electrons Can Flow and that's how you Make an on and off Switch
In How are the energy Levels
Behave in These Different Materials that's Dictated by the laws of Quantum physics and We wouldn't have been able to invent the Transistor?
Without This Understanding
Now my Technology 2 and 3
The Screen that you're Watching This on and, also the Camera that I recorded this on Which Both
Also Rely on the Quantum Physics of Semiconductors Most Screens Today a backlit by leds light emitting
Diodes and These Are Semiconductor Devices That when you apply a voltage
An Electron goes from one Semiconductor to another it loses Energy and then
Some light
So leds Have Been Gradually getting Better
Over Time and A Lot of Engineering effort has gone Into making Leds that are very Bright and also White in Color
Now Kind of the Opposite of an Led Is number Three
Which is the Sensor in My Digital Camera that Sensor
Is made Up of Loads of Tiny little Pixels Called Photo
Detectors Or Photo Diodes and These When They receive light they create a current of Electrons again Through our?
Manipulation of The Energy Levels in Semiconductors Part of the Reason why These Cameras Have kept getting better with More
Megapixels and Higher Sensitivities Is our Increasing Ability to Engineer The Quantum physics of These Semiconductors
Now Technology Number Four Is the laser in A laser you Apply Voltage to specific mixtures of Elements and
Excite the Electrons and Then They Give off Light This is Amplified With Mirrors and Finally Gives Off very Strong
Focused Monochromatic Light the Process That Lasers Use is Called
Stimulated Emission Where you Promote an Electron to a higher Energy State in One Atom
Transfer it to Another Atom and Then Those Electrons Get Knocked Down
With a Correctly tuned Theme of light Which releases more light Which is all in Phase
And to Make A laser Beam Work you need to find These Elements That Have very Similar Energy Levels again Which requires our?
Understanding of Quantum Physics Now You might be Wondering how you use laser beams Every, day, well this Video Probably got to you
Through A fiber Optic Cable as A laser Beam as Does A Huge amount, of Web Traffic these Days
Now the last Technology on my list Number 5
Is gps Technology gps Relies on?
Incredibly Accurate
Clocks on Gps Satellites The Satellites Continuously Broadcast Their Time and your Phone Takes These signals and Can Work out Where it is on Earth
Depending on How Long the signals Took to get to it
The Ticking of These Atomic Clocks Depends on the Frequency of a transition between Two Particular Energy States in A Cesium atom
Because The Frequency of These Clocks Depends on the laws of Nature all of the clocks are Exactly in Time and Are
Accurate To One Second in 1.4 Million Years
So those are my five Main
Technologies That Perhaps you Didn't know Based on the laws of Quantum physics But There's Loads of other ones That
We use in The World Today and because these, Days?
We do Pretty much everything on Computers you could argue that the entire modern World exists Because of our?
Understanding of Quantum Physics
Which is something. I don't think Many People Appreciate but I think is super cool
And in The Future There's more Quantum Technologies Coming on like Quantum Information
Quantum Computing Quantum Metrology and Quantum Simulation and Seeing How all of These develop is going to be it's going to be very Fascinating
Clearly I'm A massive Fan of Quantum Physics
But I think I'll give it A rest There thanks so much for Watching
and if You'd like to support me There's Many Different ways you can
Buy A
Poster Or a Book
We've Just Released the new Professor a stroke a tap a link to all of that in the
Description Below and Any Support on Patreon is Gratefully received Thanks for Watching and I'll see you on the next Video